[Musique]
j'ai passé ça se voit sur mon visage mes
chutes je suis vraiment heureux d'être
là vraiment de faire votre connaissance
je sais le thème de ce soir et je ne
sais pas si ça se voit aussi mais je
suis très surpris pour pas vous dire un
petit peu embarrassé je vous expliquais
après pourquoi d'abord permettez-moi de
me présenter donc je m'appelle giroux
j'ai 47 ans j'ai quatre enfants et je
suis architecte de formation
j'exerce depuis maintenant vingt ans le
métier de promoteur immobilier
alors j'adore ce moment ce qui est
toujours anti-blanc promoteurs
immobiliers que ce soit dans les dîners
ou dans les promoteurs immobiliers alors
c'est vrai qu'à la baule quand on dit
qu'on est promoteur immobilier ça prend
une tournure tout à fait particulière je
sais pas vous êtes allé chercher
ailleurs mais voilà je suis promoteur
immobilier et j'adore mon métier alors
je le disais j'ai 47 ans c'est un âge
que j'adore parce que je suis
statistiquement au milieu de ma vie si
le bon dieu me prête une vie jusqu'à 94
ans mais ça en prend bonne tournure vu
les statistiques je suis milieu de ma
vie donc je suis au régime je suis plus
un jeune con je suis pas encore un vieux
con je suis content tout court
je suis vraiment heureux et le fait
d'être qu'on m'oblige devant vous à être
devant vous en toute franchise
alors pour être franc vous parlez de
quoi de la connaissance
c'est là où je suis embarrassé regardez
d'où je viens
ça c'est mon bulletin scolaire fasse
aimer col du bac
mes notes du bac j'ai passé en 90 j'ai
fait une filière éco et
j'ai commencé voilà neuf coefficient 3
en histoire-géo philosophie 5
coefficient 3 c'est pas drôle est sûr
c'est que huit coups sûrs quatre faut
juste vous dire que ces trois matières
sur le coeur d'une terminale bep comme
on l'appelait à l'époque alors pourquoi
je vous montre ses notes pas pour faire
l'éloge de la médiocrité ou de ma
médiocrité en l'occurrence mais juste
pour vous dire que ces trois matières
aujourd'hui constitue la structure de ma
vie professionnelle
il ne se passe pas une semaine sans que
je fasse appel directement ou
indirectement à l'une de ces trois
matières je dirais même 4 matière
puisqu'il ya histoire et géographie
alors d'où je viens je vous disais je
vais mettre un petit peu en recul ce que
c'est la place que j'avais dans les
dents dans une classe en fait j'ai passé
ma scolarité à avoir cette place
gt r j'étais au fond de la classe et je
vous assure j'ai été très heureux
j'étais très heureux pourquoi parce que
j'ai pas si vous imaginez le panorama
que vous avez vous voyez le tableau vous
voyez larchitecture de la classe et
surtout ça m'a amené à découvrir
beaucoup de choses
la première chose que j'ai découverte
c'est que j'avais toujours une vue sur
l'enseignant j'ai vu 30 ouhlala passion
d'enseignants j'ai vu parfois la
tendresse de l'enseignant j'ai vu la
technique de la pédagogie
j'ai vu aussi parfois l'épuisement de
l'enseignant
j'ai vu aussi la classe qui bougeait les
premiers de la classe qui était au
premier rang
hec centrale x sciences po
j'étais dans un collège très élitiste et
ses premiers du classement
toujours aidé et ont toujours été hyper
sympa avec moi puis derrière la
graduation se faisait il y avait cette
classe qui bougeait il y avait d epuis
avait un rapport à la connaissance qui
me dépassait complètement
pour tout vous dire je cherchais jamais
à trouver la réponse je cherchais déjà à
comprendre la question est quand il y
avait une question qui était posée par
un professeur y avait des bras qui se
levait dans tous les sens je me suis
même d'un d'un copain il avait un bras
inversé comme 56 tellement il y avait
tellement envie de répondre tellement
soif de connaissance que qu'il avait
l'indre à toute amende et j'ai découvert
finalement la beauté de l'homme et de la
femme
comment les gens apprennent leurs
connaissances à leur niveau moi le mien
est au fond de la classe
alors là je fais le malin mais j'ai
beaucoup souffert de ça parce que j'ai
découverte la connaissance c'était un
son qu'on aime était pour recevait et
quand vous avez ces notes là vous n'êtes
pas audible vous pouvez mettre un son
mais vous n'êtes pas audible et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que finalement
vous demandez parfois notamment pendant
l'adolescence si vous êtes une personne
normale et j'ai découvert il ya très peu
de temps qu'en latin le personnage ça
veut dire le masque
c'est à dire que quand vous n'avez pas
accès à cette connaissance vous devez
porter un masque
persona à travers le son la personne se
définit à travers le son qu'elle aime et
qu'elle aimait à travers son masque bien
moi mon sous un mois
c'est cette tête là autant j'ai réussi
mon bac parce que les autres note était
parfaitement conforme à toute ma
scolarité
là je me suis planté j'ai eu 14 en arts
plastiques en dessin j'ai toujours eu 20
le dessin a toujours été ma passion mon
domaine si vous permettez je vous le dis
avec beaucoup d'humilité mon domaine
d'excellence
j'adore ça c'est comme ça je vais
toujours travaillé j'ai toujours
progresser dans le dessin et quand par
exemple il s'agit de regarder un paysage
de dessiner un paysage
on peut prendre n'importe quel paysage
prendre paysages de montagne par exemple
on va dessiner la crête de la montagne
on va décider la forêt on va dessiner ce
village le clocher au milieu du village
on va dessiner cette rivière qui passe
entre deux montagnes et puis tout on va
dessiner le chat lac et là on va
dessiner les vaches mais à moi quand je
dessine un paysage d'abord je prends un
pied énorme physiquement j'adore ça sauf
que il n'ya pas que ça moi derrière
derrière quand je vois les mandats que
je parle de géologie je vais me
renseigner sur la géologie derrière
pourquoi la montagne elle a des couleurs
de roche différentes
pourquoi ce que la neige s'arrête un
niveau précis pourquoi ce que le nuage
pourquoi ce nuage et bute sur cette
crête là donc je vais réfléchir à la
question du climat et de la météorologie
pourquoi est ce que le village s'est
posée là dans un coin complètement paumé
je vais réfléchir à la question de
l'anthropologie
pourquoi il ya une église au milieu du
village réfléchir aussi à la question de
la spiritualité
je lui fais comme ça et c'est quelque
chose qui m'a toujours toujours
passionné je voudrais vous montrer cette
image
vous le reconnaissez tous cet homme a
changé ma vie un moment donné j'ai
trouvé une phrase de lui qui dit apprend
comme si tu devais vivre toujours vie
comme si tu devais mourir demain
cette phrase m'a profondément marqué
pourquoi parce que je me suis accroché à
ses connaissances à cette quête de
connaissances ce qui est étonnant
d'ailleurs c'est que je dire le prophète
du jeune de la non-violence m'a fait
découvrir que la connaissance était une
forme d'alimentation
j'avais besoin de m'alimenter à ma
manière
j'ai été gavés de connaissance pendant
toute ma scolarité et tout à coup j'ai
découvert à travers le dessin je pouvais
me nourrir à ma façon
la connaissance pour moi comme
l'alimentation est une question de
corpulence on n'est pas tous capables
d'apprendre la même chose est-ce que
vous avez nourrir un nouveau né du
cassoulet non et bien les gens qui sont
pas capable non plus de se nourrir de se
nourrir de chose trop importante et
cette alimentation là je les fait
progresser au fur et à mesure elle s'est
retrouvée un jour sur une place que vous
voyez ici qui est à nantes c'est la
place aristide briand sur laquelle vous
avez l'ancien tribunal de nantes la
gendarmerie la prison de l'anc la maison
de l'avocat c'est la place de la justice
j'avais eu la chance il ya six ans de
livrer ce bâtiment qui était
donc à l'ancien tribunal on a transformé
en hôtel en hôtel de luxe
transformer un lieu de rigueur et de et
de répression en un lieu d'accueil et de
douceur c'était le thème de ce projet là
je vous le montre parce qu'en fait je
vais vous parler du projet d'à côté et
ce projet la côte est vous voyez si la
place aristide briand
c'est la prison de nantes les prisons de
nantes
vous connaissez tous ma chanson je vais
pas vous la chanter parce que demain de
votre douche
vous l'aurez encore en tête et vous
n'aurez aucun doute sur le fait que
nantes se situent bien en bretagne les
prisons de nantes
c'est un sujet qui a qui m'a réveillé
kim a foudroyé un moment donné c'est là
que je me suis rendu compte que mon
métier promoteurs ça veut dire
promouvoir quelque chose mouvoir le
mouvement la promotion c'est le
mouvement quelque chose est bien dans la
conception de la créativité la
connaissance et le seul nutriments pour
nous mettre en mouvement et ce mouvement
a créé ce projet là la première des
choses que nous avons faites par rapport
à la question du mouvement c'est de
modéliser 7
ce bâtiment là vous avez la modélisation
exacte des anciennes prisons de nantes
avec ce grand mur d'enceinte
on a modélisé le bâtiment on l'a
soulevée du sol environ 50 mètres de
hauteur on lui attribue un poids
numériquement et on l'a fait tomber au
sol et voilà ce que ça a donné
on a voulu signifier qu' on ne faisait
pas table rase du passé dans la
connaissance mais que ont soulevé
l'histoire en un serveur se reposer au
sol il ya dix morceaux qui se sont créés
et s'est passé autre chose hélas cette
deuxième traumatisme professionnels que
j'ai connu c'est que dans la dans le
terme promouvoir la promotion et à la
question du mouvement mais ce qu'on sait
moins c'est que le mouvement
l'étymologie du mot mouvement ces mots
verrez c'est la même étymologie que le
mot émotions
et là on s'est dit qu'est ce qu'on peut
mélanger l'émotion et le mouvement et
avec mes équipes
on a fait un travail de recherche de
connaissances des études psychiatrique
des études sociologiques des études
fonctionnelles sur les prisons et on
s'est rendu compte par le plus grand des
hasards que les grandes 6 4 ont établi
que lorsque vous enfermer un homme ou
une femme
il se produit en lui du traumatisme
profond il ya peu près dix étapes je
vais pas voir vos le temps de vous
voulez développer tout ce soir mais je
voudrais vous en donner quelques unes
la première étape c'est la question de
la sidération
lorsqu'on ans ferme un homme ou une
femme
il est sidéré par ce qui lui arrive
qu'est-ce qu'on a d'autres ici qu'un
plan en sidération
sidération c'est le sidéral c'est
épouser l'ensemble de ce qui nous
entoure la désorientation
il m'est arrivé lorsqu'on a visité
lorsqu'on a gagné ce concours
on a visité la prison est évidemment une
cinquantaine de fois il m'est arrivé de
me perdre
je connaissais le bâtiment par coeur il
m'est arrivé de me perdre ses bâtiments
on est aussi était conçu pour qu' il n'y
ait plus d'orientation et quand vous
regardez le plan masse de ce projet vous
n'avez rien d'autre qu'une boussole et
c'est pas nous qui lavons dessinée c'est
cette chute qui l'a créé
on s'est questionné aussi sur les
traumatismes psychologiques que vivent
les prévenus ou les détenus il y en a un
qui est très important qui est celui de
l' isolement évidemment lorsque vous
rentrez dans une prison vous baissez la
tête j'avais eu l'occasion de visiter
cette maison d'arrêt lors du chantier du
tribunal pour des raisons techniques
j'étais rentré dans cette prison vous
êtes saisis par le bruit vous êtes
saisis par les regards vous n'avez plus
aucune intimité
vous perdez une grande part de votre
humanité et la question de l' isolement
est au coeur d'un bâtiment carcéral
c'est ce qu'on appelle un bâtiment de
peine et non pas une peine carcérale au
judiciaire
une peine humaines profondes et donc on
s'est questionné à savoir qu elle l
isolement aujourd'hui dans notre société
est assez rapidement s'est retourné vers
nos racines nos anciens ceux qui nous
ont donné la vie
ceux qui nous ont légué ce que nous
avons aujourd'hui les personnes âgées
dans notre société on a oublié la vraie
reconnaissance que nous devons à nos
anciens et vous avez un bâtiment qui est
totalement dédié à ces personnes on a
inventé un modèle avec un bailleur
social nantais qui a accepté de faire
l'exercice
un modèle où vous avez appartement en
communauté alors parfois on l'appelle sa
colocation cohabitation d'un nom pour
moi c'est un appartement communauté vous
avez un séjour commun chacun sachant
moins il ya un règlement
chaque semaine une personne va s'occuper
de la cuisine et du ménage l'autre des
courses etc etc
chacun a une fonction dans la
copropriété art
chaussé de ses appartements là on a mis
une crèche c'est la dèche
familiarisation 80 % des détenus
refusent de voir leur famille dans les
deux premiers mois de leur incarcération
pour par montrer l'image ils ont des
familles risation autres points
lorsque vous êtes dans un milieu
carcéral que vous êtes enfermé vous
n'avez pas de lumière ou peu vous avez
du bruit les médecins expliquent
scientifiquement que le corps se referme
que vous commencez à avoir des céphalées
que vous commencez à plisser les yeux il
explose physique qui se passe et c'est
vrai que je vous le disais que quand
vous rentrez dans une prison baisser la
tête et vous marchez différemment il ya
également une sclérose psychique ou vous
enfermez vous n'avez plus l'intimité
venaient plus d'identité vous enfermer
et donc la sclérose psychique
on a décidé avec mes collaborateurs de
faire appel à des associations qui
oeuvrent pour les personnes qui sont
victimes de troubles psychiques et vous
avez sur la gauche du projet
vous avez un bâtiment à rez-de-chaussée
qui est entièrement dédiée à des
personnes donc 700 m² à des personnes
victimes de troubles schizophréniques 35
% des détenus souffle le sou de troubles
schizophréniques et 10% de la population
enfin il ya évidemment un sujet présent
en prison permanence et la tristesse le
bâtiment ancien que vous voyez au milieu
a été conservé et ce sera un théâtre
avec un restaurant et j'espère que
dedans il y aura des stand-up
j'espère que demain on ira du rire voilà
tous ses atouts ses antagonismes qui
toutes ses connaissances qui à un moment
donné conjuguer forme le projet que vous
avez sous les yeux
alors pour ça c'est très simple on
dessine les choses on dessine la
connaissance des autres car mon métier
ça n'est rien d'autre que de rassembler
les merveilleuses connaissance que tout
le monde a en un objet cet objet il est
en pierre
ce qu'on appelle l' architecture je
voudrais vous raconter un conte là qui
nous amène à la question de la
connaissance comme une quête de vérité
où la connaissance comme l'outil de la
vérité 50 arabe qui raconte ce si un
jour le dieu créateur
mettez qui vous voulez derrière cette
notion le dieu créateur observer la
terre il fut tellement émue de la beauté
de la beauté de sa création qu'il décida
d'offrir aux hommes ce qu'il avait de
plus cher le plus beau la vérité et
cette vérité c'est un immense miroir
d'une pureté absolue et il décide de
déposer sur terre mais tellement ému
qu'il a trébuché et ce miroir c'est
s'est cassé en autant de morceaux qui y
vivent et d'hommes et de femmes sur la
terre et là les hommes les femmes ont vu
ça et on ramasse et j'ai un petit objet
là j'ai retrouvé dans les coulisses
d'ailleurs ont ramassé chacun un petit
morceau de ce miroir et on dit à la
lumière se reflète dedans
je me vois dedans je vois mon voisin
qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
que j'ai accès à la connaissance et les
hommes ont commencé à échanger leurs
connaissances
et puis peu à peu les hommes ont
commencé à tirer à temps ma connaissance
est plus importante que la tienne
regarde le morceau de miroir et les plus
importants puis l'autre a dit omc
l'autre s'est enfermé un d'autres qui
seront enfermés qu'ils sont nos enfants
on envoie moi ma connaissance elle tient
qu'à ça
puis un ado qui ont des horaires moi
j'ai ma connaissance et en voulant
montrer sa connaissance à l'autre a
commencé à le blesser évidemment et on
dit que c'est comme ça que sont nées les
guerres enfin c'est le conte qui dit ça
que sont nées les guerres la jalousie
l'avidité
on raconte aussi qu'un petit enfant
s'est approché d'un autre en disant
tiens
montre moi ta connaissance et s'est
rendu compte que ces deux morceaux de
connaissances se connecter puis un
troisième est arrivé et a fait la même
chose et on dit c'est le compte qu'il
dit que les hommes ont commencé à
rassembler comme ça
tous ces morceaux et le conte dit que ça
s'appelle la paix la connaissance
éléments ultime parfois du pouvoir de la
connaissance de l'autre de la
reconnaissance de la connaissance naître
avec l'autre et si je voudrais être
je vous remercie de m'avoir écouté je
voudrais être entendus sur une chose
c'est que à l'exemple de ce compte
à l'exemple des projets que je vous ai
montré fait par plein de collaborateurs
et bien ne sous-estimez jamais votre
niveau de connaissance il n'y en a pas
de petites de grandes ya juste un puzzle
à reconstituer
n'écoutez jamais les gens qui vous
disent je le sais plus que toi j'en suis
témoin de par mon parcours
et pour conclure je voudrais juste
vous remercier de m'avoir écouté et de
vous remercier car cette expérience que
je fais devant vous m'a permis de
comprendre une chose je voudrais surtout
parler des autres jusque encore une fois
mon métier c'est de rassembler la
connaissance des autres je vous ai parlé
des autres et pour moi le travail que
j'ai pu faire pour la préparation de ce
petit exposé ça m'a fait comprendre une
chose c'est que le contraire de la
connaissance
ça n'est pas l'ignorance le contraire de
la connaissance pour moi c'est la
malchance
merci vous
[Applaudissements]